welcome Wow hope you brought your
swimsuit and sure for Spencer and Heidi
left their glamorous Hollywood Hills
lives for serene beachfront living in
Santa Barbara just a little more relaxed
and at the beach there's not paparazzi
everywhere it's a lot of privacy but I'm
not sure people are lining up good see
Heidi and Spencer but I'm happy to
report our favorite furniture from the
heels is still there it's a little
detail for the pad it's the same insects
we do have the arcade games from the
hills they came with us we even added a
gonna added one you're still collecting
crystal right yeah it's still got it but
now I've learned they do not at least
mine don't have magical powers oh my god
Heidi just pulled up
most of these are back from the hills
days that when it was just like let's
spend money because we think we're Will
Smith and Jada you know so there it fun
to look at this was the one that got us
up into crystals because when after
Heidi's surgical procedures painkillers
didn't work shoes and so much paints on
googling like homeopathic remedies in
this it said sugar light so then I go by
this sugar light and then Heidi that
night
whether it's perfect in my hand
naturally right there whether whether or
not it's a placebo factor about that
night she said I felt no pain so then it
was on I was like all right close your
eyes I was like every crystal we need
them but that that's why I feel it I
feel a crystal look I'm cooling a rock
yeah wow that's let's get let's get
let's get let's put on your third eye
it's this a real thing or you drop
fashion on named Joe no no it's in books
what it was yes it is breathing in here
that's what they say to do I haven't
figured out what happens after that part
but is it supposed to get rid of paint
what this is supposed to open up your
heart chakra love you know I don't have
oh no yeah I'm the real sense
saij the same watching this later the
moon